it's a poetic moment that I on Iran was
born 107 years ago and we are
green-lighting Atlas Shrugged part 2
today you know I an R and she felt I
think as an individualist she could have
chosen one word to exemplify what what
she meant what was important to her and
all 1,200 pages it will be one word
reason and here we are so it's a poetic
moment as I said we're going to have a
budget that's about fifty percent larger
than part one so we're well positioned
to in October before the election of
2012 we will have theatrical release in
five hundred theaters during the first
two weeks of October
and I like Harmon kaslo to come up here
and go through the ceremony in any other
comments and and thank you too Scott and
Mila to who've been part of this thank
you gently John he it takes a lot of
people and money to get a movie made it
takes it takes the same actually to
market it and create awareness and
interest and you know one of the things
that John and I you know made the
decision that you know there wasn't
going to be a Hollywood studio number
one that would even get a clue as to
what Atlas Shrugged was all about how to
reach that audience to how to support a
film that has such an important and
powerful message so we decided to reach
out to a variety of groups and reason is
one of those groups and we want to
recognize their contribution not only
did they help us in the marketing of the
movie but then they also as I'm sure
you're all aware they partnered with us
on these DVDs we want to recognize David
not what we've done is we've taken some
cells from the actual prints that were
in theaters you know people who saw
these films in large part because of
your support and help and John and I are
incredibly appreciative of reason and
your support and hope that we get it for
part two thank you you're very welcome
and then finally one last thing we're
all here to drink right so everyone you
have a champagne glass for a reason and
it's no coincidence by the way that we
would make the announcement of you know
part 2 going into production especially
when there was a period of time where
there was some doubt as to whether or
not to be continuation of the telling of
this incredible story and so it's no
coincidence that John and I chose not
only this place at this time but also
this day to make this announcement to
you so we want to you sort of raise our
glasses here and let's not only have a
toast to sort of the adventure that is
before bill John and I
in bringing this movie to the theaters
but also to recognize the birthday of a
vine ran and have a moment of
celebration for her contribution to this
country so here here
you